great news fatties scientists are
promising that soon you will be able to
have your cake and eat it too
researchers at the University of Texas
have been testing a new drug called CPAC
cpacc that has proven to Stave off
weight gain in mice no matter how much
the mice stuffed their fat little rodent
faces the drug works by inhibiting the
way that magnesium flows through
mitochondria which is the part of the
cell responsible for producing energy
excess magnesium seems to slow
mitochondria's ability to burn calories
so the drug mimics the deletion of the
protein coding Gene that controls the
flow of magnesium thus limiting it and
effectively increasing the body's
metabolism which is all a dazzling feat
of science
but I have another suggestion
rather than squander countless resources
man hours dollars laboratory equipment
so on
trying to figure out how to counteract
the consequences of people's gluttony
what if we just encouraged people to put
the cupcakes down
I know weight loss is difficult for some
some people have it harder than others
but this magic experimental pill that
rewires your body chemistry
doesn't seem like the best solution
it isn't a solution at all because
obesity isn't the cause of people's
problems but a symptom of people's
problems
modern liberal pill popping scientific
culture constantly treats symptoms as
causes
are you depressed pop a Xanax don't
worry about working on your marriage or
reconciling with your father or finally
finishing that degree or getting a job
even maybe dare I suggest it going to
church to recognize the meaning and
purpose in your life no don't worry
about that don't worry about that
unshakable existential on we caused by a
lack of faith which is the substance of
things hoped for in the evidence of
things unseen no just drug yourself
all better having trouble sleeping well
don't worry about exercising or trying
to relax or cutting down on the partying
or no I don't
just take a sleeping pill
are you feeling fat well don't change
your diet and address the causes of your
gluttony and compulsive eating no no
just we got a pill for that too
and these pills are always marketed as
healthy for you but in fact not only are
they not healthy they are actively
harmful
because the depression the insomnia the
Obesity name whatever other nasty
outcome you want
those are all symptoms of deeper
problems vices bad habits unresolved
issues in your life and they can
sometimes these little pills they can
sometimes mask the problem at least for
a little bit
but by leaving the underlying cause
unaddressed by leaving all the bad
habits in place they will ultimately
only make the problem worse that is
because the problem ultimately isn't
that you're a little chubby or a little
tired or a little depressed the problem
ultimately is called concupiscence the
inclination to sin caused by the fall of
Man you want five cupcakes because your
ancestor ate an apple quacks have been
trying for Millennia to find a magic
man-made workaround for that one and
every single time they've tried the
problems only seem to get worse I'm
Michael Knowles as the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show the people want
Trump to debate Trump does not want to
debate that people want Trump to debate
we'll get to that in a second first
though
apropos of nothing
Chris Christie
Chris Christie has just visited Ukraine
uh he's visited Ukraine
and he's done so on a mission to bring
Ukraine President Vladimir zielinski
some Bon Jovi memorabilia
John wrote out the lyrics uh to the song
It's My Life which serves as an
inspiration for a lot of the citizens in
in Odessa as they were preparing for the
invasion by the Russians he wrote it out
in his own hands got it framed and I
brought it to president zielinski
presented to him and said that this is
representative of many of the American
people and what they feel about the
cause that's being fought for in Ukraine
and who support Ukrainian people against
Russian barbarism and uh we got a good
laugh over it about two guys from New
Jersey trying to be supportive of what's
happening over uh in Ukraine for the
Ukrainian people and so
um I I was happy to do that and to be
able to show him that there's lots of
folks over here in fact hundreds of
millions of Americans who believe that
the Ukrainian cause is just
there's also lots of folks over in Kiev
there's also lots of folks
from America who seem to be flying in
and out of Ukraine to hang out with
zelinski and take photos for glossy
magazines and do long interviews and
bring him memorabilia from 1980s rock
stars and they seem to be doing it
pretty easily
for a war-torn country
that it would seem to undercut the
argument that Ukraine is in this state
of Total War it's the most perilous
moment for the for Europe in the last 70
years when Chris Christie sees fit to
fly in hang out with his buddy have a
few laughs over
look I like Bon Jovi but you know it's
my life it's now or never this is just
not this doesn't seem like a good
a good use of War resources and it would
seem to undercut the argument that we
need to keep sending 10 bazillion
dollars over to Ukraine because it's on
the brink of collapse and we're going to
head into World War III a lot of Tourism
for a war zone
so what's the point of this trip
other than to have a talking point for
Chris Christie on the campaign Trail and
on CNN the point of this trip why would
the former Governor of New Jersey who's
now running for president in a long shot
bid why would he go to Ukraine
especially when Ukraine would seem to be
maybe not according to the liberal media
but would seem to be just according to
the conservatives I talked to not the
most popular issue with the GOP base the
point of that trip
is to signal
to the liberal establishment that a
president Christie would accept the
state department foreign policy
Mike Pence just went over to Ukraine too
to Signal his support for the the state
department policy that he will continue
this war
the point of which I'm not quite certain
and the end point of which I'm not quite
sure when that would be
that's different than say a trump who
says I'll end the war immediately that's
different than a DeSantis who
has been a little vague or on the issue
but he's
broadly signaled that he's in opposition
to continuing to fund this war
in in contrast to Vivek ramaswamy who's
within the top three candidates now same
thing
you're seeing that big split
the GOP Insurgency which says we're
going to upend the foreign policy that
has defined both parties for the last 40
years maybe more than 40 years
the UNA party
and
The Establishment more
establishment-leaning people who say no
we're not going to change foreign policy
at all and what's what's crazy about the
moment that we're in right now this
populist moment in the GOP and a little
bit for the Democrats is that the
Insurgent part the the Insurgent group
the populists who say we want a totally
new foreign policy those are the guys
who are currently winning the other guys
are Chris Christie when you want to
protect yourself against the
machinations not just of the deep state
but deep big Tech you got to check out
expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com
do you know what big Tech and big
government have in common they're both
big and they both want to silence any
dissenting voices into submission let's
say you're a proud gun owner and want to
talk on social media about the right to
bear arms well chances are that your
post will be flagged by a Content
moderator and you might end up on some
kind of government watch list to fight
back against having your voice censored
I recommend expressvpn the problem with
big Tech is that not only do they
attempt to censor you but they also
track what you're doing online what
you're searching for the videos that you
watch everything you click they can
match your activity to your true
identity using your device's unique IP
address when I use expressvpn they can't
see my IP address at all my identity is
anonymized by a secure VPN server plus
expressvpn encrypts 100 of my my
internet data for protection from
hackers and eavesdroppers expressvpn is
by far the best one I've tried it's
super easy even a lot out like me can do
it rated number one by CNET Business
Insider countless other Tech
Publications right now go to
expressvpn.com get three extra months
for free
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn.com
Knowles to learn more
Americans are done with the war in
Ukraine
The Establishment will constantly tell
us no actually the support for Ukraine
pulls very high in the GOP it's just you
crazy Tucker Carlson Donald Trump Mega
populist conservatives you guys are
Fringe if you think that maybe the
perpetuation of the war in Ukraine is
not a great idea no the the majority of
Americans and the majority of
Republicans majority of conservatives
the good conservatives they they support
the ongoing war in Ukraine that isn't
true it just isn't true we have a new
survey app that shows it and this is a
survey
that uh
that shows that 1200 adult respondents
in this poll conducted by SSRS among
them 55 said Congress should not approve
additional funding to Ukraine
45 supported more funding so
not saying it's 70 30 I'm not saying
it's 80 20. but it's 55 45 it's a clear
majority of Americans and Democrats are
much more likely to support the war in
Ukraine so among Republicans it's pretty
clear
they want to wind down the war in
Ukraine and this marks a reversal of
that CNN poll that was conducted uh
shortly after Russia invaded in February
of 2022 which found that 62 percent of
Americans wanted the U.S to do more to
help Ukraine well now they're saying No
thank you so it will change depending on
how the question is asked but money
talks and Bs walks and when people are
asked should we continue to send money
and therefore arms and Munitions and all
these other resources to prolong the war
to keep the war in Ukraine going
majority of Americans say no
which we I could have told you before
even with the stupid CNN polls because
the the poll that matters on this issue
is the pull of the GOP Primary and every
top candidate by a long shot is saying
we want to wind down this war
now
the most populous Canada in the race
coincidentally maybe not so
coincidentally is the Canada who's
winning by a landslide right now Donald
Trump is dominating the field everywhere
and he's increasing his lead
and as that is happening the number two
candidate Ron DeSantis who is going to
be the main Challenger to Donald Trump
is collapsing not just in the National
polls but even in those early primary
states that will will decide whether or
not his campaign gets to continue on or
whether it flops including in New
Hampshire Ron DeSantis has just dropped
a single digits in New Hampshire very
very bad news for
the governor
Trump right now in New Hampshire is at
43 percent no other candidate comes
close uh DeSantis and Chris Christie
actually tie for second place in New
Hampshire New Hampshire is notoriously a
weird state where the more liberal
Republican candidates generally can do
better John McCain staked a lot of his
campaign on that Mitt Romney John
Huntsman when he was running for
president Chris Christie now too even
with Trump is still Far and Away the
number one guy
the reason this is so brutal for
DeSantis is that
the DeSantis Mojo was based largely on
The View that he could win
the primary in the general he's the only
candidate who can beat Trump in the
primary and he's a candidate much better
positioned to defeat Joe Biden in the
general that was the argument
so
yes the campaign was premised on him
being a good Governor yes the campaign
was premised on him doing well with
donors yes the campaign was premised on
him having a clear political Vision he's
got all those things
but
the the main factor here when you're
talking about going up against Donald
Trump who's running effectively as an
incumbent is that he could win so the
moment that it seems that DeSantis can't
win it's not just that his campaign is
gradually going to dropped her up drop a
little bit it's going to start to drop
precipitously as we have already seen
Trump's campaign Ironically in the minds
of some people
is not premised on the idea that he
could win this is what we heard a lot
from the never trumpers in 2016 who some
of whom came around to Trump but then
basically most of them Mike cernovich
made this point most of them are back to
hating Trump now in 2024. now that
there's a at least a somewhat credible
Challenger to him they always said
Trump's whole campaign is just premised
on him being a winner a win-win-win
winner winners never lose losers never
win you know don't be a big loser with a
big L on your head I'm a winner right so
their thesis was the moment that Trump
loses
he collapses
and that obviously hasn't happened this
is what is causing the people who oppose
Trump and the GOP to want to pull their
hair out as you're saying he lost 25
midterms they kind of exaggerate the way
that he allegedly lost the midterms or
they'll say his candidates that he
endorsed lost some of whom did lose some
of whom didn't lose or they'll say well
Trump lost in 2020 and that one is
indisputable you might say the election
was rigged you might say the election
was stolen but he isn't President right
now so you could say that you say okay
here's the here's the testing of this
hypothesis Trump lost in 2020 at least
in as much as he is not the president
right now has he lost the support of his
base no his support has grown
so that thesis which is the crucial
thesis forget about DeSantis I'm not
blaming DeSantis for this I think this
was a just built into the nature of this
race against Donald Trump but it means
that any Challenger candidate is screwed
or will have an extremely uphill battle
because
that that vulnerability of trump
in being viewed as a loser
appears not to be much of a
vulnerability at all
these guys got so much wrong about Trump
I was talking to a friend of mine about
this the other day one of the other
knocks on Trump is that on the point of
populism is that he's a demagogue oh
Trump is just a total demagogue he goes
around he'll Pander to anybody
what we've seen over the years is that
really isn't true you could you could
attack Trump for all sorts of different
reasons but you can't really attack him
for being a demagogue because demagogues
are people who just tell the audience
whatever the audience wants to hear
they change their tune with every single
campaign appearance
Trump famously infamously doesn't do
that Trump is like a broken record he
never stops going on about the things
that he goes on about this has been one
of the criticisms of his campaign is he
won't shut up about the 2020 election
even though it might hurt him in the
polls well yeah maybe it'll hurt him in
the polls maybe it won't but he just
keeps talking about it he's stuck to his
same issues again and again and again
much more so than other candidates who I
think can can more rightly be accused of
demagoguery someone like a Chris
Christie could much more rightly be
accused of demagoguery than somebody
such as Donald Trump so in any case
DeSantis understands that his campaign
is in a lot of trouble that the
situation is quite dangerous so he has
fired his campaign manager
DeSantis has replaced campaign manager
Genera Peck with James uthmeyer who has
served as his office as chief of staff
for a long time uh and Peck is not going
to be totally canned from the campaign
she is now the chief strategist of the
campaign but she's not going to be
running those day-to-day operations that
a campaign manager needs to let me tell
you something here if you get fired in a
campaign people try to put a lot of
blame on you
they just they just make you a scapegoat
they throw you under the bus
I don't really blame Genera Peck for the
collapse of the DeSantis campaign
or maybe it's not fair to call it a
collapse it has been a bit of a collapse
but there's still hope he's not out of
the race yet uh but I don't blame her I
don't really blame the the fundraiser
certainly I don't really blame the
strategists I don't blame the candidate
I think the I think these are all pretty
talented people who've done a pretty
good job in politics
it's the circumstance
as I've said from the beginning I know I
know everyone now is the primary heats
up they're all trying to say oh the the
other candidate is evil if you're on the
de Santa Trump is stupid and dumb and
evil and bad and he's inevitably going
to lose all the same stuff we heard in
2016. and if you're on the Trump Camp
you're gonna say oh de Santa sees a
rhino shill he's incompetent he's weird
he's this he said I don't think any of
that's true
these are these are both strong
candidates strong politicians they've
done very good stuff they've got
sophisticated campaign teams around them
they've got somewhat Accenture campaign
teams around them both of them
it's the circumstances
which was always the issue if you're
going to blame the DeSantis campaign for
anything it's just for them
miscalculating
the strength of trump going into this
election
which some of us who I don't I'm not
endorsing in 2025 no intention of
endorsing in the primary I'm not working
for any campaign unlike it would seem
many other GOP commentators and
conservative writers
I just don't see how you have this
historic situation where you've got a
major question mark around an election
2020 and you've got a candidate running
for the first time since 1888 for a
non-consecutive second term and you've
got this guy Donald Trump who has remade
the GOP after his own image and broken
from 20 30 years of basically unchanged
GOP dog monies he's LED this kind of
populist Insurgency alongside a populist
wave throughout the West in England with
the brexit in Hungary with Victor Urban
in Italy with Georgia Maloney in France
with Le Pen in Spain in Sweden in
Germany now you've got this this perfect
moment for a candidate like Trump
I'm not saying it's impossible to beat
them it's not there's still a chance
that a candidate whether it's DeSantis
or someone else could beat him but the
odds are just pretty low and they're all
they're all going to want to blame the
candidate it's not about those other
candidates it's not about the staffers
it's not about the campaigns
it's about Trump
that's it guys
that's it and any campaign that wants to
take him on needs to see that fact very
clearly
when you want to be able to run a solid
organization you've got to understand
people and their roles in those
organizations which is why you got to
check out ZipRecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you are
hiring you know that it is incredibly
hard to attract top talent with the
current labor market conditions it is
even harder than ever that is why you
want a partner like Zip recruiter zip
recruiter gets it zip recruiter knows
how tough it is right now they've
figured out solutions for the problems
that you are facing try them at
ziprecruiter.com
for free to reach more of the right
people so recruiter posts your job to
100 plus job sites sip recruiter smart
technology finds great matches for your
job and that lets you invite the most
qualified people to apply their pricing
is very straightforward so you can stick
to your budget with no surprises team up
with a hiring partner such as zip
recruiter that understands what you need
four out of five employers who post to
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day
just go to this exclusive web address to
try ZipRecruiter for free it is
ziprecruiter.com Knowles that is
zippercruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire
speaking of trump and weaknesses he does
have one apparent weakness right now
right now at this particular moment
which is Trump doesn't want to debate of
course he doesn't want to debate he's 30
points up in the race and he realizes
that a debate entails a lot of risk
because all these candidates are going
to be taking shots at him
and not much upside so he's going to
increase his lead what from 30 to 33
points that's not a lot of upside but
there is a lot of risk if he has one of
these bumbling moments you know a Marco
Rubio glitching out kind of moment or
Rick Perry he forgets the third point in
the series or I don't know any any of
these moments they happen during all
sorts of debates
Mondale during Reagan got absolutely
destroyed by one debate
Trump says okay I don't want to I don't
want to debate the problem for him is
his base wants him to they're all saying
is he going to go into the debate and I
said I don't know if you're leading by
50 and 60 and 70 points do you do that
or not I don't know should I okay you
ready
should I do the debate
thank you
well maybe we'll do something else you
know see some people say yes but they
hate to say it because it doesn't make
sense to do it if you're leading by so
much but they like it for entertainment
value because they're selfish
they're selfish okay so he he misjudged
that one he usually has his finger on
the pulse of a crowd really well that
one he misjudged and he misjudged it he
thought he had them because he did a
little test right because does it make
sense for someone who's up by a
bazillion points to debate no so he's
thinking oh good okay so now I can prove
that my audience doesn't want me to
debate and say okay good let's do a poll
should I debate
this is the uh Caprice of crowds yes we
do want you to debate and he's there and
he goes shoot oh man he doesn't he
doesn't break his smile the guy knows
Show Business show must go on because I
shoot ah darn I didn't see that one
coming okay yes no but
and I think quite rightly he says you
only want me to debate because you'll
find it entertaining right and what did
they say yes that's exactly why we want
you to debate he goes yeah okay that's
very selfish you know and he's kind of
joking about it a little bit but it does
expose a real weakness in the campaign
right now
which is everybody knows that Trump
doesn't really stand to gain very much
from debating
and everyone wants him to debate
including his most fervent supporters
if I were advising Trump right now if I
were on the campaign I'd say don't
debate at least not the first one see
how it shakes out
but
if I were in that crowd at that rally
you know I would have been there yeah
you definitely should debate it's going
to be awesome you're gonna make Jeb the
high five you or whatever you're gonna
make fun of Rand Paul's face I don't
know you're gonna do those things that
are so mean and nasty and entertaining
you're going to talk about Rosie
O'Donnell what was it you say the only
woman you've ever insulted is Rosie
O'Donnell
it's going to be funny but there's not a
lot to
is not a lot to be gained from it so he
kind of saved it there at the end or
maybe we'll do something else okay you
guys are selfish come on get out of here
you come on stop it but a bit of a bit
of a misstep or a
miscalculation and he's gonna have to
play it very carefully because the other
the other field the rest of the field is
going to call him a coward
and he's got to make sure the that if if
the people pulling in single digits call
him a coward
doesn't matter but if his own audience
if he doesn't give his audience what
they want
that's a much bigger problem
so what's Trump's best bet here Trump's
best bet in the campaign
is to keep getting indicted that's the
best bet that's what continues to make
the show all about him
and most Americans are on board with
that
most Americans believe that the
indictments are a political hack job to
derail the Trump campaign this is not
just according to me this is not just
according to the conservatives this is
according to a CBS very left-wing CBS
yougov poll
set they say that most Americans view
these indictments as quote an attempt to
stop the Trump 2024 presidential
campaign
59 say yes that's what it is 41 say no
it's not now this is contrary to what
Trump's opponents are saying
Trump's opponents in the GOP are saying
that no the indictments are actually a
5D chess move to make Trump the nominee
because these Democrats they know that
that it's going to help Trump in the
polls so it's going to make Trump the
nominee and so really yeah it looks like
they're trying to throw him in jail and
trying to disqualify him from the ballot
and trying to execute him or whatever
whatever it is they're trying to do but
no but secretly actually they want him
to be the nominee that's what they're
trying to do I think this is a cope from
the second and third tier candidates I
think the proof that this is not true is
that the Democrats have been trying to
do this since before they really thought
he was a viable candidate they've been
trying to do this since 2016. this exact
same thing they've been trying to bring
bogus charges against him they've been
spying on his campaign they've they have
been Prosecuting him since he was in
office they've had special counsel after
special counsel going after him I I just
don't I don't think if all of this began
in 2024 maybe you could make a case for
that but but I I think the simpler
answer is the correct one here they view
him as a legitimate threat
that's the issue and that's why people
still like Trump sometimes people write
into me they'll say Michael why are you
giving Trump a fair Shake why aren't you
working for the DeSantis campaign or
aren't you working for the Vivek
campaign or I don't know why aren't you
working for some other candidate
campaign why is it that you're fair to
Trump
what I see in Trump
is
something above the ordinary level of
politics what do you think about
abortion what do you think about
immigration what do you think about
taxes what do you think what I see in
Trump is something that is metapolitical
which is that his very existence as a
candidate and a politician
throws a wrench in the machine of our
political order the machine of our
political order which has a dominant
liberal part and a minor Junior partner
conservative part
but they all play their parts
PJ O'Rourke who is a conservative
satirist libertarian conservative
satirist very funny guy
he much to his dismay endorsed Hillary
in 2016. he was one of the never
trumpers and he was he was one of the
few insightful
honest never trumpers in his endorsement
when he said I endorse Hillary and all
her lies and all her empty promises
she's evil and she's awful but she's
Evil Within ordinary bounds
saying I'd rather the devil I know than
potentially the devil I don't
you don't know if he's a devil or not
but you don't you just don't know Trump
is a kind of a foreign thing who upsets
Orthodoxy not just on the on the liberal
side but on the right as well
what's he going to do is he gonna
start blabbing about secrets on Iranian
military policy and Bedminster oh what's
he going to do does is he gonna is he
gonna just blab about something on TV
he's not couth he's not trained he
didn't go to some Think Tank
he's not he's not a member of the
Council on Foreign Relations you know
he's just not clubbable this guy
that that's what people say I'm not I'm
not saying that's a sufficient reason to
it support him I'm saying that's why
people do support him that's why many of
the most right-wing figures many of the
most conservative people will support
Trump even if Trump is a little
squishier on the LGBT issues than other
candidates than Ronda Santas say even if
Trump is a little bit squishier even on
abortion I mean you have to give Trump
credit for abortion in that he got Roe v
Wade overruled he picked the judges who
got review rate overruled and he picked
good enough judges to do it unlike say
George Bush trying to nominate Harry
Harriet Myers George H.W bush uh
nominating David souter even Ronald
Reagan nominating Sandra Day O'Connor
even if Trump just picked the list that
was in front of him he picked very
relatively very solid judges
so you can but but when he talks about
abortion he sounds squishier often than
many of the other GOP candidates why do
the hardcore people tend to support
Trump
it's because of that meta-political
issue because of populism
because he represents a wrench in the
system for Better or For Worse you might
say that our system doesn't need any
more wrenches you might say our system
needs a lot more wrenches but the proof
of this too is that you're not only
seeing it on the right you're seeing on
the left too Trump is not the only
populist candidate in this race the
other clear populist candidates not even
Bobby Kennedy he's got a little bit of
that but it's Cornell West Cornell West
is a left Winger he is a guy who's
taught at Princeton Harvard very
eccentric academic who's come out with a
rap album and he has wears kind of silly
clothing and has always got like big
hair a big beard and he just looks like
a wild man and he talks like a wild guy
and it was a pretty interesting
political figure and he's running for
president now so Cornell West is running
and what do you know
now that some polls are showing that
Cornell West if he runs third party
could tip the election to Donald Trump
if Trump's a nominee what do you know
that we've seen some polls about that
well all of a sudden Cornell West has
some tax issues
all of a sudden the IRS is discovered uh
Cornell West he's got some real problem
we got to investigate Cornell West
the new Republic here ostensibly a
liberal outlet but it's kind of
establishment liberal so Carl here's a
new report new report Cornell West owes
the IRS more than half a million dollars
in taxes
oh here we go the investigation was
first put out by The Daily Beast
establishment liberal Outlet not radical
left
not conservative no it's establishment
Liberal oh yeah he owes 543 778.78
um
it's going to complicate his long shot
bid his third party bid that maybe could
pull enough populists from the left who
don't like establishment liberal Biden
but can't bring themselves to vote for
right-wing populist Trump I mean we love
over Cornell well maybe that's enough to
swing the election to Trump can't have
that think we're going to have to
investigate him and indict him just a a
smaller version of what they're doing to
Donald Trump
he owes half a million in taxes okay you
know what Mike maybe he does maybe he
probably does
if you if you make money from lots of
different income sources that sort of
thing can happen I mean you hope it
doesn't get to that point half a million
that's a lot of money but it can happen
when I was a kid I always wondered how
did Wesley Snipes get in trouble with
the IRS how does someone end up owing a
million dollars to the IRS can't you
just pay your taxes but these guys are
are making money from lots of different
sources it's not like they just file a
W-2 and have their employers deduct the
taxes so things can spin out of control
if you're irresponsible with your money
okay let's say he owes half a million in
taxes
how much tax has Joe Biden how much tax
have Joe and Hunter Biden paid on that
10 million bribe they got from Ukraine
because they're in the highest tax
bracket let's say it's a little less
than this let's just say just for ease
they should give half of that away to
the government
it'd be a little less about half let's
say
it's on 10 Bill 10 million dollar bribe
oh bribes are illegal by the way so
they'd probably have to be investigated
for that but let's say it were legal
income 10 million that means they would
owe five million dollars in taxes that
they certainly have not paid
that's 10 times
well Cornell West allegedly owes the IRS
how come the IRS isn't sicking its
agents after Joe Biden
he's done 10 times the crime forget
about Hunter already has outstanding tax
problems
they're only going after Cornell West
what's that about what's that about um I
do you think it has to do with that
specific crime
with an intentional kind of tax evasion
or
do you think it has to do
with the fact that Cornell West is a
populist and he is not going to win
but if he did win or even just by
running he throws a wrench into the
system so then the the
election comes down to a question
do you believe
that the political order is still
sufficiently fair and just and stable
that one can do the most good
by
operating basically within the normal
bounds of that system
or do you think that the political order
has become so degraded and corrupted
that the political order is so clearly
rigged against
conservatives and just ordinary normal
people who want an ordinary normal good
country
that's been so rigged against them that
the only way to correct that system is
to throw a wrench in it gum up the works
a little bit and then reshape the system
that's that's what the debate is about
which is why people who tend to be a
little bit more Centrist people who tend
to be a little bit more establishment
people who seem to be a little bit more
content with the way the system is
running
they're never going to go along with
Trump they can't do it or a candidate
like a Cornell West or to some degree
even a Bobby Kennedy
they're going to go for the other GOP
candidates or they're going to go for
Joe Biden or they're going to go for a
Hillary Clinton or they're going to go
for a Gavin Newsom type character
but if you think the system's gotten
a little bit beyond repair from just the
ordinary mechanisms
you're going to be attracted to those
populist candidates and the liberal
establishment knows that which is why
the liberal establishment is bringing
out its enforcement arm it's thugs it's
coppers it's it's agents it's deep
Staters it's everything to stop their
campaigns before they can take off to
kill that baby in the Cradle whether it
is changing the definition of words or
trying to convince you that two plus two
actually equals five it sometimes feels
like the current culture is doing its
best to make you stupid when wokeness is
permeating every aspect of your life
it's difficult to know where to turn for
guidance well
you can check out our good buddy Dennis
Prager he's got answers in his daily
wire plus series prageru Masters program
and master's program Dennis has gathered
40 years worth of wisdom and is sharing
it on a wide ranging number of subjects
Dennis offers useful advice on marriage
happiness and how to be a good person
plus so much more he even dares to
explain the differences between men and
women in a world that wants to make you
woke Dennis wants to make you wise all
episodes are now available only for
daily wire Plus members go to
dailywordplus.com
become a member watch prageru master's
program today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
awga-3
who says when I see a YouTube episode
that's only 35 minutes I know Michael
has been extra spicy today that's true
and I apologize for it folks I know that
when when I talk about subjects that are
overlords at YouTube won't don't want us
to talk about then it's got to come out
of the YouTube show and so that
condenses the show the that they add to
content ratio I know is a little bit
higher I know I appreciate your patience
with that
that's why you got to go to daily wire
plus it's why you gotta you can check
out the full show uncensored on Twitter
at M knoll's show
but
I will not censor myself for YouTube I'm
just not going to do it I am not going
to allow Google to
incentivize me successfully to edit my
show I'm not going to allow the most
powerful tech company on planet Earth to
put enough sticks and carrots in front
of and behind me to get me to to stop
talking about one of the most important
social issues around today I'm not going
to do that
I'm not going to Nuke my YouTube channel
for no reason I think we need to be wise
as serpents and innocentist dubs but I'm
not going to mess up the show so the
full version of the show is going to go
out on RSS Apple podcast Spotify
Stitcher it's going to go out on Twitter
it's going to go out on ML show it's
going to go out on daily wire plus and
then the parts that are allowed on
YouTube we're going to put on YouTube
and that's it but we will not
we will not let these guys beat us
whether by scaring us whether by paying
us off or anything like we're not going
to do that we're going to keep talking
about that issue we're just going to
keep talking about it it's Alienware
Plus
okay
speaking of politicians in precarious
situations
Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell has been
heckled with chance to retire it's
because he had some kind of a medical
incident it seems where he froze up
during a press conference had to be
escorted away from the lectern I was
back on the trail and and hecklers are
chanting that he's too old and he's got
to retire
[Applause]
so David back his introduction is longer
than my speech
Elaine and I are really excited to be
back at Fancy Farm
on behalf of the strongest Republican
team we've ever run in our state
for those of you who keep count this is
my 28th Fancy Farm
about 28 fancy Farms
I want to thank Father vendors and
Stephen Elder
for finding a way to keep Fancy Farm
going even with pork prices going
through the roots
thanks to the Kentucky State Police
rough it's rough for McConnell he is a
total Pro politician and so he works
through it just fine whatever that
Health scare was doesn't seem to have
really slowed him down all that much
it's still pretty good on his feet as
far as politicians come
people are are calling on him to retire
I'm of two minds on this
on the one hand
the guy's pretty good at wielding power
I know I don't know in his heart of
hearts is he really a true conservative
I don't know I do know that he got Roe v
Wade overruled and the guy deserves as
much credit As Trump does on that point
because he held that seat open amid a
lot of political pressure he held that
seat on the Supreme Court open until the
elections one of the reasons Trump got
elected one of the big reasons Trump got
elected and then they got a good judge
confirmed they got a number of good
judges confirmed they ever ruled rovy
Wade so I think the guy deserves a lot
of credit it is his lasting Legacy he
said it's his lasting Legacy so I like
him I have a lot of affection for Mitch
McConnell for that reason for that
reason alone that would be enough
now
I know he's a little old and and
I was just in Hungary the Hungarian
government is relatively quite young and
they're getting a lot of great stuff
done so maybe that would be good to have
energetic young conservatives out out
there in the United States advancing the
the next stage of the conservative
vision and not stuck in the old
platitudes of the past okay yeah
I guess here's my counter though to that
point
do we have any evidence that Mitch
McConnell's replacement is going to be
any better than he is do we have any
evidence of that whatsoever do we have
any evidence that the guy who's going to
replace McConnell is more conservative
more energetic better Adept at wielding
power I don't see any evidence of that
the guys who might replace Mitch
McConnell
are John barasso John thune or John
cornyn the John caucus is looking really
strong at replacing Mitch McConnell as
the Republican leader in the Senate and
I like these guys personally they're
very nice guys I have nothing against
them whatsoever I'm not saying they
would be so much worse than Mitch
McConnell but I don't
I don't see any evidence that they would
be so much more conservative so much
more energetic and effective I just
don't see it
which is why I can't get on the whole
deposed McConnell train
that's why I can't get on the deposed
Putin train all the really excitable
liberals the interventionists who want
to just go bomb every country on Earth
they said we need to depose Vladimir
Putin we need regime change in Moscow
to which I say oh yeah
for what
for what who's going to replace Putin
none of them know none of them have an
answer to that
some of them sometimes say Alexi navalny
because it's the one other politician
name they've ever heard of in Russia
he's the leader of the opposition who
spent some time in America now he's in
prison it's not going to be navalny guys
the guy's in prison okay
by the way what do you know about Alexi
navalny nothing nobody knows anything
about these guys
but it won't be him anyway it'll be
potentially a much more dangerous
adversary a much less prudent uh wise
adversary than Putin I'm not saying
Putin's a great guy
but
if you're if you're telling me that he's
so bad that we need to bring the force
of the United States to depose the
leader of a nuclear reform or superpower
can you at least tell me who the
alternative is
who's going to come next no of course
not which is how we get into these
bungled foreign policy messes that lead
us into quagmires for decades and
decades
what's the same kind of thinking going
on here
show me who's going to replace McConnell
who's going to be the the right wing far
more conservative far more effective
leader I just don't see it
speaking of relevance this is going to
be a little bit of a tease you know I'm
such a tease on this show
there's a writer's strike going on in
Hollywood I had forgotten this actually
until I saw a news article about it
I'd forgotten it because I don't watch
much TV or movies
I saw barbie that was the first movie
I'd seen in a while and I only did it
because daily wear made me
and I ended up enjoying it I watch maybe
maybe a show at night maybe most nights
I don't even watch a show
if I watch a show though I'll watch one
episode of a show
and usually it's going to be some show
that's been on forever
always sunny or something like that so I
don't care about the new content coming
out of Hollywood
the actors I think are still on strike
again who cares I just don't consume
enough of this stuff especially the new
content doesn't really matter
what about the late night comedy shows
remember late night comedy used to be
the staple of network TV
lately The Tonight Show the light show
late night comedy shows have been off
the air for three months
did you know that
it didn't know that
I didn't know I'm not saying this just
to diss them or to dunk on Jimmy
kimmelers
I had no idea that they had been off the
air for three months which tells you a
lot about our changing media and
political landscape we'll get to that
tomorrow the rest of the show continues
now it's woke Wednesday baby you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
Knowles Canada wlas at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]